what the [ __ ] is happening ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
in the country give it up for my friend
hogg's gym
[Music]
hey keep it going for joe [ __ ]
rogan in the house
[ __ ] yeah
he's gonna be here in austin texas
i'm also a southerner from south korea
there's only two things i like shooting
comedies in
kingpin uh my name is hans uh my eyes
are open right now i know i have really
small eyes
uh but luckily the lord blessed me with
a long face so that way when i'm getting
a girl out i can still make eye contact
i love being asian orthodox country
chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to japan province
i love it i love it here uh
i uh i think it's great that
tanner is a white person's name i mean
who doesn't love that
tanner than one
i should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
i love being here opening for joe rogan
i'm also actually a practitioner of
brazilian jiu jitsu that's uh
those are the guys that can kick your
ass over there
uh brazilian jiu jitsu it's like normal
jiu-jitsu except you try to shave your
opponent's pubic hairs off
oh yeah yeah
you only play once a month
i am uh trying to work out i'm trying to
get enough mass so that if a girl puts
her hand on my chest i don't have to
take a step backwards
because i'm straight as [ __ ] uh i love
the ladies i don't think i could ever
[ __ ] a dude sorry fellas
i've never looked at a beautiful woman
and been like wow is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier less
there's less kindness
i'm gonna stick that in my butthole
straight as [ __ ]
please believe me my dad doesn't
a lot of ladies call me a premature
ejaculator which hurts my feelings
premature
i came right at the perfect time but i
felt amazing
so i am single
a lot of
people give me dating advice so like you
need to learn how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to haunts
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
this one girl was like did you know that
my vagina can make a baby so my vagina
is a 3d printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer
your vagina is the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
takes nine months to print
and the whole time this printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not see any trays
at night
but i'm allowed to say that because i'm
gender fluid i'm biologically male but
my bullies identified me as a [ __ ]
very gender food
i love how millennials nowadays are such
narcissists and if we're not a seven or
above we'll just chop our dick up and
change our gender
why don't you just be a four and learn
how to play guitar
[Applause]
i
support the cause i mean i'm not a
racist of course i'm a minority how
could i be impossible
i don't even see race i only smell it
especially in those ubers
whoa
all the grounds from over there that's
where the uber drivers are sitting
now you can afford a ticket
but uh
i don't i don't mean to brag
but i do deliver for ubereats
i like to deliver for ubereats on my
college sweatshirt that way people can
see that the system isn't working
i saw a truck on the side of the road
that said you can hire me for 20 an hour
and i was like damn that truck makes
twice what i make
i could be doubling my salary right now
as a truck
pretty poor i live in a band so that i
can pursue comedy full-time so please
laugh
it's hard to date inside of a van
because ladies and shelters like this
whole thing with them
so even if the date goes well what
usually ends up happening is we go for a
drive until i can mark up the courage
until we arrive 45 minutes or more
these love fan surprises
um it's hard to date as an asian man
everyone thinks asian women are sexy but
how do you think asian women are created
i mean [ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
and that support too
asian women act like they're hotter than
asian men but we look exactly the same
[ __ ]
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
[Applause]
why are you always bragging that you can
[ __ ] white dudes i can [ __ ] white dudes
i can all [ __ ] white dudes
i know asian women are hot here in
america but back home we're throwing
them away
are you guys gonna cancel me for an
asian joke i'm asian
let me say that
we're really doing it we're throwing
away it's crazy
um my sister actually just got back from
a mission trip if you don't know that as
a mission trip is where americans go to
different old countries to get new
profile pictures
she was like did you know that your
toilet water is cleaner than the
drinking water in africa
i think these are the pipes that we have
what do you want me to do about
it if i see an african walking down the
street i'll let a drink from my toilet
it's not a problem
just flush afterwards i don't want to
get aids
i'm not a racist
impossible
i um
i was actually on an airplane and i saw
a dude reading a book in arabic which
kind of freaked me out
but then i saw him fold the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
happy ending
uh my favorite marvel movie is a black
panther movie uh because the black
panther movie it was a great movie and
it also gave black children hero they
could look up to and not just someone
like martha king jr malcolm x harriet
tubman thurgood marshall george
washington carver nelson mandela rosa
parks
wilson and morgan freeman fitchburg
tupac baby obama oprah
[Applause]
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
he's got little cat ears but he's an
asian school girl
where are they gonna come out with a
yellow panda huh what the [ __ ]
it's gonna eat your furniture
but i experienced a lot of racism you
know a lot of people who races don't
even know it this guy comes up to me and
he's like tokyo which we have this song
he's like dude just because i look like
this doesn't mean i speak your ching
chong language
[Applause]
and the post office is right there
[Applause]
i get made fun of by my asian friends
because like the general chicken
like isn't genocide's chicken just a
shitty americanized version of something
authentically asian
i was like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour and three
i love uh being here in texas i love
rednecks because rednecks can survive in
any wilderness situation that you put
them in
except the situation where everyone has
equal rights
[Applause]
we can live in a swamp with an alligator
why can't you live in a cul-de-sac with
a minority
all right that's what i thought thank
you guys very much
we have got a great comedy show for you
tonight
next comic you might have seen this
comic on the joe rogan podcaster
headlining all over the [ __ ] country
please get up for ally mccoskey
[Applause]